[Music]
that they don't teach you at University
what's going on team my name is David
tomage I'm a registered architect here
in Western Australia and this is part
eight of the arcade course today we're
talking about roofs and all of the finer
details that they simply just don't tell
you about and expect you to know if
you've been on the channel for a while
now you may have noticed just a small
tweak to that little introduction from
guys to team and that's for a very
simple reason 20 of you watching right
now are female and that is incredible to
see the demographic changing so thank
you so much for being a part of the team
let's get started with today's tutorial
moving on to part 8 which is our roof
design you notice that I went ahead and
created this master suite on the right
from part seven just like we discussed
if you want to copy it take a screenshot
go ahead go for it but let's move on to
the actual roof if we jump across the 3D
we'll see the roof has nothing going on
it's pretty basic it's pretty boring
nothing special whatsoever but we do
want to make it something special we do
want to make it something exciting so
how do we do that well first of all
let's discuss what the actual roof
styles are and the roof types are so
let's jump back to the first floor go to
our roof tool over here on the left hand
panel
it simply looks like an A-frame roof
select our roof tool make sure it's on
the right layer as always and then we
have two options we have a single plane
and we have a multi-plane roof option
the multiplane is going to create a
typical and traditional hip and Valley
roof I'm going to start with this one
because we're not actually going to use
it I don't like them too much they're
great in particular use cases but not
for this design today
so to create a traditional hip and
Valley roof you simply select one of the
corners on the outside making sure that
your reference line which is the first
line of this selection is correct that
depends on your wall structure your roof
type if it's steel or Timber how you're
pitching it Etc but for the purposes of
today we are literally just going to
trace around the outside of our building
perimeter if I finish that box you're
going to see it immediately creates this
hip and Valley roof so I'm going to
bring that to the front to Showcase it
in front of all of my furniture you'll
see there are a number of parts to this
roof as it stands but I know it's on the
wrong layer straight away so I'm going
to click command T change it for my
first floor to my roof plan and press OK
Now command up you'll see it on the
floor above command down you will see it
disappear if I come into my 3D once
again you'll see that roof created and
it is looking pretty good pretty quickly
it's not too shabby it's pretty basic
but it does the job and if you've never
used a human value roof you probably
have no idea what any of these parts
caught I'm going to jump back to our
dear friend Luis ferocio and just
showcase one of his great pictures from
his ebook which explains quite a few of
the elements straight away so if we look
at this picture here you'll see that the
gutters are the elements around the
perimeter of the roof that capture the
water they are always well most
typically the lowest point of the roof
and that section
so in our instance the gutter would be
positioned right here if we were to
create a roof now graphisoft has CI
tools built in so you can go coverings
roof coverings and select a corrugated
roof very quickly press OK and it will
create a 3D corrugated roof now this
roof again is a paid extension paid
add-on to arcad you may or may not have
it but that's simply you see the gutter
created at the bottom if you don't have
it not a problem we're not really going
to be talking about the 3D cladding too
much I'm simply going to undo that step
and keep going talking about the highest
point in the roof line of the hip and
Valley roof is the ridge now the ridge
is this line at the very top it's also
this line at the very top the ridge is
again the uppermost like a Ridgeview
Mountain once again talking about those
hips and those valleys and those
mountains the valley itself is the part
of the roof that falls in between two
sections towards a guard
so this section right here would be our
Valley in the roof and you would have a
valley gut up technically inside that
falling into your downpipes and together
along the perimeter the opposite of the
valley is obviously the hip hips and the
valleys and in our case the hips are
right here they're like the hips of a
person they point up towards the middle
of the spine so you can almost see a
small person here if you draw a really
funny picture so for me personally just
because this is how my brain works you
would see
a person's legs here you would see their
body here there's one arm there's
potentially another one over there and
there's a random head so we have our
funny man from our hip and Valley roof
alongside all of these elements of
course you're gonna have extra things
like Dormers and skylights ridges and
bits and pieces here and there but
typically that is most of the
information you need to know about a hip
and Valley roof if I was to put back the
4D cladding you'd see a few extra items
as well first of all you'd see the hip
flashing which covers the two cladding
elements on the each side you'd see the
ridge flashing and you would also see
the valley gutter now that corrugated
tin comes all the way across that
baligata sits underneath the corrugated
tin so the water doesn't circulate and
the pressure isn't built up push backed
in cause water problems so the water
naturally falls down the ribs of the
corrugated into the valley gutter into
our gutters on the side and then you
would have the down pipe connected as
well now there's no down pipes drawn on
this for whatever particular reason at
the moment if I go back to my first
floor plan command up I can simply
create a quick gutter just to Showcase
it to you guys here that right there is
our downpipe from our gutter now and if
you've never seen a downpipe in a gutter
what it does is basically control the
flow of water off the roof into the
ground and away from the house it is
critical that you do not let the water
simply just stop right here next to the
foundations of the house because those
foundations will over time fall away the
ground will Decay and the house will
collapse so be smart with your water get
the plumber to Route the water away
correctly into soap Wells and just get
that water away from the foundations of
your house once again this cladding not
important so let's simply select it all
delete it and move away I don't think
I've actually spoken about this find and
select tool so let's undo that and
showcase that once again for you guys if
you press command or control F you can
activate the find and select tool if you
can't find it there help find and select
it's also in your edit menu down the
bottom there to use the find and select
tool you can either go through one by
one select the individual item you want
add additional information and filtering
tools such as surface color or even the
surface name or anything you want in
between but simply you select one item
you ask it to select the properties it
finds all those properties and then you
can select everything similar you can be
as specific as you want with this or
very generic just to get rid of all roof
coverings in this instance what we've
done now is basically explained a hip
and Valley roof very very quickly and we
can delete it because we don't want it
we don't need it it's ugly a quick
little interlude from me to tell you
three things one the Discord link down
below is full of great Architects and
students from around the world just
looking to better themselves it's
completely free so please join it number
two below that is a patreon link if you
want any of the archicad files that I've
used specifically for YouTube you can
download them via a patreon subscription
and last but not least throughout this
entire video we have been referencing
the graphic guide to residential design
you can grab your copy of the ebook in
the description down below it is a
phenomenal resource and well worth the
money if we move back down to our first
floor plan just so we can see what's
going on select our roof tool again and
select the infamous single pane roof the
this thing is a pain because you're
going to have to redraw and reconnect
every single section of a roof if you do
a hip and Valley roof this way if you're
doing a skillion roof a mono pitch roof
a shed roof whatever you call it around
the world this is the way you do it
simply select that single plane select
the lowest point of your roof which for
me will be this back side put it on the
side you want the roof to go up and then
start by drawing your roof for me in
this instance I want all of the walls on
the outside to be parapets and I'll
explain what that means in a second
so what I'm going to have to do is draw
on the inside of my exterior walls this
time except for the very bottom one
where my gut is going to be so drawing
on the inside of every single one
connecting finishing off
coming back to our 3D we'll see our roof
again on the wrong level so change that
to roof planned press OK and it's at a
22 degree pitch doesn't need to be at 22
degrees depending on where you are in
the world depending on how much rainfall
you get depending on what if you get
snow or not you can basically go down to
as low as one degree which is one degree
and nine minutes if you're documenting
to Timber framing codes now a single
pitch roof is super basic it pitches
from the back side it goes in One
Direction all the water falls in One
Direction and you have downpipes only on
one side and one gutter on one side
the disadvantage is you basically need
to select all of your external walls
increase the overall height of these
walls which increases the budget at
least 150 millimeters past the cladding
now this is just the roof structure not
the cladding so I'd probably go anywhere
from about 300 mil plus this which means
our Wall height is 3 900 millimeters
I can easily just connect this as well
by duplicating that wall hiding it and
creating that little box but there we
have a skillion roof where you basically
don't see the roof whatsoever it is
completely concealed and if we were to
once again go to our CI tools coverings
root coverings again paid feature you
may or may not have this
it will create our roof what we didn't
discuss in the hip and Valley roof is
what the sides here are called and if I
select my roof go to my coverings and
edit my edges it'll allow me to explain
that a little bit better so this one is
backwards Upside Down based on the image
I'm showing you the gutter this line
here is actually the bottom side where
our gutter is visible this on the side
has created a barge a junction a barge
and another Junction there's a few
different options including an apron in
this particular scenario every one of
these walls except the bottom wall here
where the gutter is would be an apron so
we would change all of our roof types
from barge and Junction to apron and
press OK you'll see the cladding style
immediately changes and the flashing
type changes you'd basically cut into
the side of this silicon join or run
that flashing all the way up over and
cap the top of this wall to protect it
from the weather if you didn't want to
extend past this wall so for instance
you wanted the roof to extend past and
so you could see the side of that actual
roof profile first of all you'd have to
trim the roof so to do so right click
our Wall come down to connect solid
element operations the wall is our
Target the roof is our operator and in
this instance we want to subtract with
an upwards Extrusion smash that execute
button and you'll see that wall is
automatically trimmed now we would have
to change our roof Edge once again here
from an apron double click on that it
will barge press ok to see that change
to a barge the barge very simple it is
the side like a barge board at the Docks
where the boats come and plow and hit
that is the exposed element to the side
of the roof just to protect the side of
the roof from everything at a junction
obviously quite simple if there was
another route falling back that way it's
a junction point where these two
elements meet so I'm not going to really
go ahead and show that but that is very
simply put all of the elements of the
roof how they operate how quickly
they're formed together and what they
need to be how they need to operate if
you wanted this roof to be a low pitch a
higher pitch or anything in between you
could now if you wanted a concrete roof
whole another kettle of fish first of
all you don't have any cladding on top
you have a flat roof zero zero this
concrete roof would then literally be
defined blend by four was in the
material itself like there is in your
bathrooms and your showers Falling
Towards different waste points in the
roof this roof would then drain either
through the building wherever possible
or it would still drain to the edge
around a box gutter which is basically a
gutter surrounded by parapets concrete
roofs are great in the right environment
if it's in snow you've got to heat them
so that the snow doesn't overload the
roof and collapse in on you and if
you're a torrential rain it isn't
recommended because you may end up with
problems as well however besides the
actual price of concrete roofs in
Australia they are awesome they look
phenomenal if you wanted to extend them
five six seven meters or past you easily
could if you wanted to cantilever
something like that create a beautiful
shading device over the side of your
house with no supporting structure
underneath you could you can't really do
that in too many other elements unless
you get massive steel columns whereas
that could probably be
350 400 ml thick of concrete
cantilevered backspan away you go but if
you did want a concrete roof you can
then extend your roof to the outside
trim all of your walls to the top of
that roof and Away you go to progress
this tutorial it's part nine where we
start looking at elevations and sections
I'm going to leave this roof as an
entire apron around all the sides so
simply undo a few of those features and
then I'm going to delete my c i
coverings tool roof because I know not
all of you will have it anyway that's
all for me today team thank you so much
for watching I hope you enjoyed the
video if you did make sure you smash
that subscribe button down below to the
side of me is the playlist that holds
all of this arcad course so far and yet
to come if you have any questions drop
them in the comments down below but like
always I'll see you next Monday